BECKY: Please join me in
welcoming to Google New York
Louisa Shafia.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Thanks Becky.
JACI BADZIN: So your book
opens with a really great
introduction to your
history and your heritage.
Can you start by telling us a
bit about your personal story
and your connection
with Persian food?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Sure,
well, my dad is from Iran.
He grew up in a town called
Qazvin, which I'm not
saying in a nearly
guttural enough way.
It's really Qazvin.
And then he moved to
Tehran as a teenager,
and then he came to
the US to Philadelphia,
to be exact, to finish
his medical degree.
So he came from a
large Muslim family,
and in Philly he met my mom, who
is an American Ashkenazi Jew.
JACI BADZIN: Very interesting.
LOUISA SHAFIA: And they fell
in love and got married.
And so I grew up with a
very diverse household
in Philadelphia, and
as most Iranian men,
my dad wasn't doing
a ton of cooking,
but my mom wanted to make
the dishes of his homeland
that he loved so she
really taught herself
how to make Persian dishes.
And so maybe once every
few weeks on a Sunday
my mom would start
the long, slow process
of making a big
Persian feast for us.
And my dad would help.
I've got to give him credit.
He would help.
These flavors we're kind
of my every day flavors.
They were just part of my world.
It wasn't until I was
an adult and really
exploring all different
kinds of culinary traditions
that I kind of realized
this awesome food heritage
that I have.
JACI BADZIN: Did you grew
up cooking with your mom
or was it something you
explored later on in life?
How did you find that
interest in cooking?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Yes, I
was recruited by my mom
around age five-- no joke, to
help prepare for dinner parties
and gatherings that
she would have.
My mom loves to entertain, and
she's an amazing cook herself.
I'm sure that's where I got
the bug to love to cook.
And she would have
us, my sister and I,
prepare crudites platters
and very simple desserts
and omelets.
And so I just grew up
feeling very comfortable
experimenting with
food, so that's
for sure where it comes from.
JACI BADZIN: That's
so interesting.
And this is your second
cookbook that's out,
and you've also written
numerous articles
for publications, "Food 52,"
the "Wall Street Journal."
How did you get interested
in writing about food?
Was that something that
was also from a young age
or was it something that you
found when you were older?
LOUISA SHAFIA: I
really got into writing
after I had my catering
company for a couple of years.
I had a catering company
called Lucid Food that
was all about sustainable
catering, really bringing
the world of eco-friendly
thinking and locavore approach
to eating to the
world of fine-dining,
doing something more interesting
than pigs in blankets
at nice corporate events.
And people got really
excited that you
could have these beautiful,
elegant hors d'oeuvres that
were all sourced from
the farmer's market,
and everything was being
composted along the way.
And no one was really doing
it in New York at that time,
and people were so curious
and excited by this
because they hadn't really come
across it before that that's
when I got inspired to write
my first cookbook, which
is "Seasonal Cooking
and Eco-friendly
Tips for the Kitchen."
and I just kind of wanted
to take all that experience that
I got with my catering company,
and all those things I
shared and share them
with a bigger
audience in a book.
JACI BADZIN: So this book
is called, the new book,
is called "The New
Persian Kitchen."
What is your definition of
the new Persian kitchen?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Well, the
new Persian kitchen-- well,
I should say in
context, Persian cooking
has a very different
timeline than say,
American cooking or
even European cooking.
Persian cooking goes back
literally thousands of years.
So at the ruins of Persepolis,
which was the ancient ritual
capital of the
Persian Empire, what
is now modern day Iran, the
makings of fesenjoon stew,
which is one of the most iconic
stews eaten today in Iran.
It's made from ground walnuts
and pomegranate molasses.
All the makings of that were
found written on stone tablets
at Persepolis.
So even back then, they
were using pomegranates.
They were using walnuts.
They were using parsley.
They were using garlic.
So when you say the
new Persian kitchen,
it's taking something
that's very ancient
and kind of riffing on it.
So I'm sort of doing a
take on Persian food that's
very much inspired by
this ancient cuisine,
by the very sensuous
ingredients, like saffron
and rose water and
sumac, and filtering it
through my own very
healthy way of eating.
So putting in whole grains,
instead of white rice.
Cutting back on sugar, really
trying to put the emphasis back
on fresh fruits and
vegetables, which really
are the foundation
of Persian food.
JACI BADZIN: So the inspiration
for this cookbook would be,
was it founded more
in your heritage?
Was it wanting to express
your new techniques
and connect them
back with your roots?
Where did this inspiration
come from to write this book?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Well, I entered
the professional culinary world
with a very strong focus
on healthy cooking.
In fact, I was vegan when I
started my career as a chef.
JACI BADZIN: That's interesting.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Yes, and I
went to a very healthy cooking
school.
It's called the Natural
Gourmet Institute.
It's here in New York, and
I was vegan at the time.
I entered-- all of my
teachers at the school
were middle-aged women, and
they all told me being vegan
was the worst thing I
could do for my health.
So I left cooking
school no longer vegan,
and after I finished, I
moved to San Francisco
to cook at this awesome vegan
restaurant called Millennium.
And I have to say
one of my first meals
in San Francisco
was at Luna Park,
and I had fish for the
first time in a few years.
I'm bringing that up because
you said you used to work there.
JACI BADZIN: That's how
I got my start at Google,
as a hostess at Luna Park, in
case you guys are wondering.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Great restaurant.
JACI BADZIN: It's
a great restaurant.
Still open, too.
LOUISA SHAFIA:
Still going strong.
Yeah, I started cooking
at Millennium, loved it.
Was so inspired by all
the different ingredients
we were using.
In San Francisco at the
time, that was 2001.
Everyone was already deeply
into the locavore thing,
and we had farmers coming to
the back door of the restaurant
dropping off foraged
mushrooms and chilies
and all kinds of cool things.
So one day, my chef asked
me if I would come up
with a new dish for the menu.
And we were already using a
huge diversity of ingredients,
Korean things, Japanese,
African, and my first thought
was what can I do that
no one's done here yet?
And I knew nobody had
done Persian food.
I just knew it,
because there's not
a lot of Persians or Persian
restaurants in the Bay Area.
And so I thought, I
think I'll try fesenjoon,
which is pomegranate and
walnut stew usually made
with either turkey or
chicken or sometimes, duck.
And I did a vegan version of it.
The ingredients are magical.
That combination of the bitter
walnuts and the tart and sweet
pomegranate, that's
all you need.
And it almost doesn't matter
if there's meat in it or not,
it's just so good.
So I didn't know how to cook
with any Persian ingredients
at that time.
It was a huge process
of discovery for me.
And I found some
different versions
of recipes for fesenjoon, and
I muddled my way through it,
and came up with something.
Everyone tasted it, and
said, whoa, what is this?
This is so great.
It's sweet, and it's tart, and
its rich, and it's beautiful.
I added some grated
red beets to the dish
to make it a beautiful
deep red color.
And it went on the menu,
and everyone liked it.
And that was really the
start of me discovering
this amazing food heritage
that I had grown up
with but I'd never
been aware of.
JACI BADZIN: So cool.
Do you find that there's an
opening within vegan style
food for more Persian cooking?
It feels like it'd
be a pretty good fit.
I mean, yes, there's the
yogurt, and there's the meat,
but do you think that
there is an opportunity
to expand that vegan
lifestyle with more
immersion of Persian
food in the ingredients?
Do you think there's--
LOUISA SHAFIA: Absolutely.
Persian food is all
about the flavors.
And traditionally, meat
was used to just boost
the flavor of things.
It never had a starring role.
It's only kind of now
that meat is so much
more accessible and cheap that
you'll see these huge kabob
fests and super meaty stews.
But traditionally, meat
was just a small element,
and you can do these dishes
completely without meat.
If you're doing-- there's
all these classic stews,
like fesenjoon,
there's bademjoon,
which is eggplant
and tomato stew.
There's ghormeh
sabzi, which is herbs.
It's all green herbs.
When it's finished it's this
beautiful vibrant green color.
And it's really
flavored with something
called dried limes, which
is a very particular Persian
ingredient.
And it's kind of
like lime times 12,
because you cook
with the whole lime.
JACI BADZIN: I read
that in your book,
and was like, what
is this dried lime?
I want to try it.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Oh,
they're so good.
They're super sweet and kind
of bitter at the same time.
But it's all about those
flavors so you really
don't need the meat.
And in my cookbook, I try
and give vegetarian or even
a vegan version of all
of the meat dishes,
because the whole
point is to make
use of the fruits
and vegetables.
And here, I want to point
out that Iran always
had an abundance of fresh
fruits and vegetables
and herbs, very
much unlike a lot
of other parts of
the Middle East.
But Iran has a
temperate climate.
It has four seasons.
It's surrounded by two
mountain ranges that
are covered with snow
throughout the whole year, which
most people, I'm sure, think
of Iran as a big desert.
But it's not.
There's marshy areas and
meadows and mountain ranges
and very, very
diverse geography.
But the ancient
Iranians figured out
a way to bring the melted
snow water from the mountains
into vast desert areas and
have these lush gardens growing
in the desert.
JACI BADZIN: And the
irrigation systems
are something that's
known historically,
that they've been
able to develop
these amazing lush
gardens and it's
depicted in books and
stories and movies,
and it's really fascinating.
And I feel like that comes
across in your book really
well through your writings,
but also through the imagery
and through your emphasis
on herbs and on produce.
And even taking the
different-- like the limes,
which were fantastic.
There's a bit about
the caramelized onions
too that it just--
it's so interesting how
you take fresh ingredients,
and you can just
build and build and build
these really amazing dishes.
LOUISA SHAFIA:
Yes, and thank you
for bringing up the
caramelized onions.
Caramelized onions
is something you
see in many, many
Persian dishes.
It's often used as a
topping for things,
and that is a great way to
bring a foundation of really
deep, rich flavor into a dish,
even if it doesn't have meat.
So if you're trying to make
these dishes vegetarian,
take the time to make
some really nice,
slowly cooked
caramelized onions.
They will fill in for
the flavor of meat
and really round out a dish
in a very powerful way.
It takes a little time.
They can take about an hour
to really do it the right way.
You start on high heat with
your thinly sliced onions,
then reduce the heat and
just let them cook down
and cook down until they're
really dark and just
a fraction of their size.
And they're sweet
and rich and smokey.
Everything you want.
JACI BADZIN: So good.
Do we have caramelized
onions today in the cafe?
I hope we do
LOUISA SHAFIA: I hope we
do after that description.
So talking, again, there's these
amazing traditional ingredients
and your culinary interest
and personal interest in vegan
food, the recipes
in this book are
really-- they are a mix of
traditional and innovative.
And can you tell us a bit about
how you created the recipes
in this book, and how this
collection came together?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Sure.
Well, it was kind of a
process of discovery.
I had originally wanted to go
research this cookbook in Iran,
but I wasn't able to get
the documentation to go,
and I was very sad about that.
And then a friend of
mine said, why don't you
just go to Los Angeles?
And if you don't
know, Los Angeles
has the biggest Iranian
population outside of Iran.
And a lot of my extended
Iranian family is out there.
I have at least 20
family members out there.
And I thought,
that's a great idea,
because I won't have to wear
a chador and cover my head,
and I'll be able to get around.
And I speak the
language, English.
So I went out there and kind of
in my honor of being out there,
we had all these
amazing family feasts.
It was so cool.
These all day feasts.
You get there at 12:00
or 1:00 on a Sunday,
and you leave at
maybe 9:00 or 10:00.
You've had about
three rounds of food,
and you're just feeling super
happy and tons of black tea
in between every meal.
And from that, I got to see the
favorite dishes that everybody
made, sholeh zard, the sweet
rice pudding with saffron rice,
with dates, adas polo, all
these different dishes.
So I got to see the ones
my family members really
loved and I got to taste those.
And I thought, OK, I
really like this one.
I like that one.
I'm going to try my
own recipe for this.
And then my relatives
took the time
to get in the kitchen with me.
So I would come over for
these intense all day
cooking sessions
with my cousins,
and they showed me
really step-by-step
how they made some of
their favorite dishes
like rice with fava beans
and dill, which is just
a beautiful dish for any
time that stuff is in season.
And so I really
learned that way.
And then being there,
I was able to shop
at all these Persian
grocery stores because I
had all the ingredients
on hand like I had never
had in New York.
So I could get rose petals,
I could get date syrup,
dried limes, barberries,
anything I needed
and just play around and
experiment in my kitchen.
And so through that
process I kind of chose
some of those classic dishes
from the Persian cannon.
They kind of have a cannon
of classic rice dishes,
classic stews, classic desserts.
So I took some of
those and then I just
created some that were
inspired by-- like there's
a chicken dish in the book.
It's turmeric chicken
with sumac and line.
And I really wanted to have--
JACI BADZIN: It's
featured today.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Yes,
is on today's menu.
JACI BADZIN: It looks so good.
LOUISA SHAFIA: I can't wait
to taste their version of it.
But I wanted to make a
dish that encapsulated
all the flavors
of Persian cooking
but didn't take several
hours and only used
a handful of ingredients.
So you just season the
chicken thighs or breasts
with a little bit of turmeric
and salt, sear them in a pan,
then add some water
and garlic and let
it braise for 25 minutes.
Take it out, season
with some lime juice
and some sumac powder, so you've
got a lot of tartness in there.
You've got saltiness, you've
got richness from the chicken.
And it's really
well-rounded and full so it
tastes like you were
cooking all day,
but it's kind of
for an Americans
modern tolerance of
how much time you
want to spend in the kitchen.
JACI BADZIN: It's really-- one
of the other things I loved
about this book is that it's
a book that's-- it so useful.
It so just connects immediately.
There's so many recipes
in there that you
could make in a tiny
kitchen in Manhattan.
You can also make in
a huge kitchen in LA,
and it's so approachable that
I just kept flipping through
and I was like, I want
to make this dish.
No, I want to make this dish.
It's really vibrant
and really amazing.
And the ingredients
that you talk about too
are so vast, fantastic,
but possibly not the most--
some of the ingredients, what
I thought was interesting,
is that they may not be
found in the form in the book
of the recipes, but
you give instructions
on how to make them
or even sometimes
substitutions, which I
thought was a really helpful.
If you had to suggest a
few key ingredients to have
in your house to cook from your
book or to cook Persian food,
what would they be?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Oh, I
love that question.
Turmeric would be one.
Sumac, which is a little
purple powder that
comes from the sumac
berries, not poison sumac,
just edible sumac.
They look completely different.
Two different plants.
And it sort of serves the
purpose of lemon juice,
but you don't need to
have a fresh lemon around.
It's tart and kind of salty
and actually very high
in vitamin C.
Pomegranate molasses, which is
just pomegranate juice cooked
down, again, tart and sweet.
Dried limes, which
maybe they're not
that easy to find in a store,
but there's a lot of places
you can order them online,
and they keep forever.
And I guess, dried mint, which
you can throw into any dish
and transform the flavor and
make it exotic and eastern
just by adding that at the end.
JACI BADZIN:
Interesting, dried mint.
I'm going to add that.
LOUISA SHAFIA: It's
spearmint, in particular.
So it's not peppermint, and
it's not just general mint,
it's really spearmint that
has that real fullness
and that real savory taste.
JACI BADZIN: And
the difference too.
I'm glad you clarified that.
Spearmint versus peppermint,
that's really interesting.
In your book, it states
that according to Persian
tradition foods can either heat
your body up or cool it down,
and it's typically
advised that you
keep these energies
carefully balanced.
So with that in mind, can
you recommend a balanced meal
according to Persian tradition?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Sure.
So a classic balanced
meal is actually
a kabob platter, which
is your kabobs, which
are hot by nature.
Meat is hot.
You have your rice, which can be
studded with anything from nuts
to dried fruit to
meat to fresh herbs.
You have grilled
tomatoes on there,
and then you're
always going to have
sumac sprinkled over the
rice, and that is cooling.
And you're always going
to have a glass of doogh,
which is a salty
mint yogurt soda.
It sounds weird, so delicious.
It's just yogurt with--
I like to make it
with sparkling water.
You could make it with flat.
Put a little bit of dried
mint in there, some salt,
a little bit of garlic,
and it is so good.
And that is really,
really cooling,
and that's why you
have it with that meal.
Iranians have a very
specific philosophy
about healthy eating
that, again, goes back
thousands of years, just like
ayurvedic cooking and dietary
rules.
And just like traditional
Chinese medicine,
Iranians have this
theory that goes back,
and you always want
to stay balanced.
If you get too much of
hot or too much of cold,
you're going to get sick.
JACI BADZIN: Very interesting.
Your first cookbook,
as you mentioned,
was focused on
eco-friendly food.
This book focuses
on your heritage
in more traditional
Persian elements.
Will the reader see any
similarities between the two
books or is it a
pretty different route
from your first book?
LOUISA SHAFIA: There's a lot of
common ground between the two.
It's funny, with the first
book, I only had, I guess,
a couple of chicken dishes
and some fish dishes in there.
It was really true to
my vegetarian heritage.
In this book, meat is
such of integral part
of Persian cooking.
It's really one of
the characteristics
of all these classic
Persian stews and rice,
even if it's just
a small amount.
So I really wanted to be true
to that, so I debated a while.
But I did end up including lamb,
which is the meat that you'll
find most often in Iranian
cooking, lots of chicken,
a fair amount of fish
and seafood dishes,
which they have all different
kinds of fish in Iran.
Down by the Persian
Gulf, there's one kind.
Up near the Caspian Sea,
there's different kinds.
So I did include those,
and then, I really
have an emphasis on
cooking with whole grains,
finding healthy alternatives
to maybe less healthy ways
of cooking.
If you go to a Persian
restaurant these days,
you'll often find dishes that
are made with a lot of oil.
So I have suggestions
for cutting down on oil
and also using
healthier cooking oils,
like coconut oil,
things like almond oil,
using extra virgin olive oil
for garnishing at the end.
So you can definitely
tell that both books
were written by a health nut.
That's the common ground.
JACI BADZIN: That's great.
What was your favorite
discovery of writing this book?
Your second cookbook,
so you are familiar.
You've written a
book before, but what
was your favorite discovery
of this particular journey?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Gosh, I
mean there were so many
little particular food things
that I discovered, just
like the whole
ingredient, dried mint.
I loved discovering that.
But I think the bigger thing
for me was the opportunity
to really get to know
my Persian family
and get this opportunity
to really be immersed
in the culture like I
had never been growing up
in Philadelphia.
And I think just really
understanding that,
and also understanding that I
was part of this sort of bigger
tribe, if you will,
and going out to LA
and looking around and seeing
that everybody looked like me.
That was an amazing discovery
and a completely new feeling.
JACI BADZIN: So cool.
So besides your cookbooks,
what is a cookbook
that you would recommend,
like a must-have cookbook
that you would recommend
for people to have?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Yes.
Just yesterday I
was looking at it.
It's called "The Legendary
Cuisine of Persia"
by a woman named Margaret
Shaida, S-H-A-I-D-A.
She was an English woman who
married an Iranian and lived
in Iran for decades.
She's no longer alive,
but her book is available,
and it taught me so much.
And it's got all
kinds of great stories
about the folk traditions
that are behind
a lot of the specific dishes and
the role of religion in Iran,
and the role of geography,
and how it really
affected how each
part of the country
has a very different
regional cuisine.
It's really written
in a lyrical way.
It's just beautiful, and
she put some things--
she's able to express some
things about Persian cuisine
and Persian culture in
ways that just can't even
be improved upon.
JACI BADZIN: That's good.
Making a note of that one.
So in this digital
age, technology
is so ever present,
we're at Google.
How do you see technology
changing or affecting
the way that you approach
traditional foods
or cooking or sharing
the information
about this rich
history through food?
LOUISA SHAFIA: Well, I feel
like now it's so easy with video
to show how you would make a
dish that once was believed
very, very complicated.
Like, for example,
something like
tadig, which is a traditional
part of any Persian meal.
It's the crispy rice
on the bottom of a pot,
and it's golden and
it's crisp and it
tastes like potato chips and
popcorn and fried chicken
all in one.
So if you tried to just describe
that in words, it's so subtle,
and there's so many
different little tips
that you need to carry out to
actually make it successfully.
But with a video, there's
so many great instructional
cooking videos
out there now, you
can show people exactly how
they can do it and learn
how to do it like
an expert at home.
JACI BADZIN: Yeah,
I definitely--
it's amazing to see how many--
these days, how many people are
learning to cook from
videos, and people will
find information online.
I still have my-- I
love my cookbooks.
I mean, I will
keep them forever,
but it's interesting to
see how the two compliment
each other too.
It's like book to
video, back to the book,
when you're cooking
and moving around.
And there is
something that's still
so beautiful about having that
book present in your kitchen
as opposed to a
laptop or your phone.
You can't really hold your
phone and cook at the same time.
So it's really-- I think
there's a beauty and essence
in the cookbooks and
especially in yours.
The photos are
wonderful, and you
can tell it's such a
culturally rich book.
It's really amazing.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Thank you.
Just one more thing on
that that I want to say.
Is also, with
things like Twitter
and just so much
sharing online, I
can be talking with people in
Iran and getting recipe tips,
and asking them
how they do things
and getting an
immediate response
and having this dialogue that I
really wouldn't have otherwise.
It just makes us so much
closer and makes the ability
to share ideas really easy.
JACI BADZIN: And tips,
that's really interesting.
So cool.
I love that idea of like when
you're cooking something that's
historically inherited
from a different country,
a different land,
and using technology
to get instant information
about like, oh, I'm making this.
I'm not quite sure.
Does anybody have
any recommendations?
And you can.
You can get information
just instantaneously
that shifts your entire process.
It's so interesting.
So you have two cookbooks,
a catering company,
you're a food writer, what
is going to be next for you?
LOUISA SHAFIA: I'm
really thinking about it.
I feel like I'd like to
bring these flavors to people
in an easier way, so
I'm working right now
on getting my papers
in order to visit Iran.
And, fingers crossed, that's
going to come through soon.
And if I do, and I'm able to
actually go to the motherland,
to the source of
all this, I think
I'm going to go deeper into
this approach to cooking
in this tradition of things
that come from the Silk Road.
So I kind of feel like that's
where I'm going, but we'll see.
I don't want to jinx anything
by saying it to soon.
JACI BADZIN: Silk
Road, that's amazing.
I love that thread line through
this too, the ingredients
and how you tie that in.
It's really fantastic.
What is on your
food bucket list?
JACI BADZIN: Oh, boy.
Well, one thing I
really want to do
is after I get deeper
into the Iran thing
is I'd love to explore
the heritage of my mom's
side, which is Russian,
German, and Polish.
And I would love to go
to that part of the world
and really immerse myself.
And the interesting
thing that I found,
which was really surprising
in researching this book,
is how much those two
areas have in common.
Because there's been
cultural exchange
for thousands of years,
whether it be by war
and conquering or just by trade.
But I found pickles
and dill and raw onions
and pickled fish, caviar and
lots of super sour flavors
all throughout Eastern Europe.
and then, of course, into
Iran and the Persianate sphere
of influence.
So I kind of want to go
to that part of the world
and see what all the
similarities are.
JACI BADZIN: Very cool.
So we've got a couple more
questions left, and we're
going to open it up
to the Q&A portion.
So if anybody has
questions, please
use the microphones that
are in the audience.
So I like to wrap things
up with a off the cuff
portion, finish this sentence.
So there's a few questions.
I'm inspired by--
LOUISA SHAFIA: Yotam Ottolenghi,
the author-- the co-author
with Sammi Tamimi, the
cookbook "Jerusalem."
I love how the two
of them have brought
this really exotic flavors to
a bigger audience in a really
beautiful, easy
to understand way.
And I think they've kind of
changed the whole dialogue
about cooking here.
Suddenly, everybody's super
into Middle Eastern cooking.
JACI BADZIN: Fantastic.
Three things that are
always in my fridge are--
LOUISA SHAFIA: Peanut butter,
miso paste, and tamarind pure.
JACI BADZIN: I don't know
if those three go together,
but I bet she could make
something very interesting
with them.
LOUISA SHAFIA: They can.
They all will kick up the
flavor of a bowl of ramen.
JACI BADZIN: That's amazing.
I'm going to try that.
When no one is watching, I eat--
LOUISA SHAFIA: A
big bowl of soup
that has peanut
butter and miso in it
and all different kinds of
vegetables like winter squash
and shiitakes and scallions
and ginger and carrots.
JACI BADZIN: That
sounds really good.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Had
it this morning.
JACI BADZIN: If I weren't
a chef, I would be--
LOUISA SHAFIA: I guess, I
would be a full-time writer.
JACI BADZIN: I can see
you on your way to that.
LOUISA SHAFIA: An academician.
I should be more exact.
I guess, I would delve deeply
into food history and really
the theories and the
foundations of everything.
JACI BADZIN: Very interesting.
Last question.
When Jaci comes to my house for
dinner, I'm going to make her--
LOUISA SHAFIA: I am going
to make her Persian rice
pie, which is rice with a
layer of cooked chicken,
roasted chicken, and
yogurt and barberries,
and then another layer of
rice on top cooked to a crisp
so the top is covered
with the golden tadig
and the inside is tender.
And it's comforting,
it's rich, it's savory.
JACI BADZIN: I can't wait.
LOUISA SHAFIA: It's
special occasion food.
I'm going to make it for you.
JACI BADZIN: Well,
thanks so much.
We have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First, I want us to say how I'm
kind of excited to see this,
because it seemed for
years that, at least
in English language, it was
kind of legendary cuisine.
Persia was the only cookbook
that really was available
that I could find.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Oh, you
know about that book?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, totally I know.
It's an awesome cookbook,
but I'm excited to see more.
I guess, when I think of
Iran, the first thing that
comes to other people's
minds is saffron.
They produce one of the
world's best saffron
and I was kind of
actually surprised you can
apparently what claims to
be Iranian saffron here
in the US, which I wouldn't
have thought was legal.
But where do you
think-- where should I
go to get really the best
saffron that I can find?
Do1 you mean here in New
York or just in general?
AUDIENCE: Whatever.
Here in New York.
Let's try that.
JACI BADZIN: Let's
start here in New York.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Well,
here in New York,
I usually go to Kalustyan's.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
where I would go.
JACI BADZIN: It's amazing.
LOUISA SHAFIA: But, you know,
you could also-- does Penzeys
still have a store in New York?
Penzeys, the mail-order spice
company, did they close?
Oh, that's too bad, because
they have such high quality
ingredients, even things
like sumac or saffron.
I would go to them first
because they're really fresh
and they know their sources.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
there's no secret places
like in the Iranian
community where they like--
LOUISA SHAFIA: Well,
now that you've asked.
You could go out to
Great Neck, Long Island,
where there's a big
community of Persian-Jews,
and there's grocery stores
and there's restaurants.
So you might, if you paid
off the right person,
be able to get some real
authentic Iranian saffron.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JACI BADZIN: Nice.
Well, thank you so
much for coming in.
This is so fantastic to get
to have you here and talk
about this beautiful book.
LOUISA SHAFIA: Thanks Jaci.